plus de 7200 québécois ont manifesté
leur intérêt pour aller travailler dans
les champs mais une centaine seulement
ont été jumelés à des entreprises
jusqu'à maintenant
jennifer crawford et la directrice
générale de l'association des
producteurs de fraises et de framboises
du québec
bonsoir bonsoir
est-ce que l'appel aux québécois pour
venir travailler dans les champs
fonctionne selon vous ben oui en fait ça
a très bien fonctionné on
on est très inquiets par rapport à
l'arrivée de travailleurs étrangers dont
sur les fermes québécoises on a des
travailleurs étrangers on auprès des
travailleurs locaux aussi donc on ne
parle de pas avoir assez de travailleurs
donc on a fait un appel aux québécois
puis ont répondu en grand nombre donc on
est très contents de kayes répondu à cet
appel
est ce qu'on pense que les le jumelage
autres ces travailleurs québécois qui
veulent travailler et les producteurs
sera plus grand parce que l'on parlait
de seulement une centaine
oui donc ça ne fait que commencer le
comme sa vie encore de la neige dans
certaines régions annonce le maïs cette
fin de semaine donc la saison ne fait
que commencer
donc les besoins air mais devons
augmenter à mesure que la saison
progresse et puis on va en besoin de
l'aide de travailleurs le dans les
champs dans les prochaines semaines dans
les prochains mois donc puis quand la
récolte arriver là on va vraiment besoin
de beaucoup de travailleurs donc on
espère que ces gens là ils vont être
encore disponibles quant à venir le
moment des récoltes mais avec la
réouverture de l'économie et nous savons
que ce n'est pas un travail facile
est ce que vous êtes convaincu que les
gens vont venir et vont rester ce on ne
sait pas encore on veut être réaliste le
par rapport au travail que ça représente
donc c'est un travail physique
c'est un travail à l'extérieur donc les
gens qui veulent essayer quelque chose
de différent cet été sont invités à
s'inscrire dans les centre d'emploi
agricole mais oui c'est un travail
physique et et à l'extérieur donc c'est
la réalité du travail à la ferme puis
à mesure qu'elle déconfinement se fait
au québec c'est sûr qu'il ya des gens
qui vont retourner à leur travail mais
s'ils peuvent me donner un coup de main
maintenant et dans les prochaines
semaines jusqu'à temps qu'ils retrouvent
leur poste d'un c'est tant mieux
le ministre de l'agriculture du québec
andrée lamontagne faisait cette semaine
que 85% des travailleurs étrangers
agricole pour le secteur agricole sont
arrivés au québec
est ce que vous faites le même constat
dans votre secteur mais je peux je peux
dire le contraire mais a à ma
connaissance dans les entreprises de
fraises et framboises présentement on
est plus au tour de atteindre les 50
pour sa part ça c'est vraiment parce que
des vols qui sont arrivés dans les
derniers jours et qui sont arrivés
aujourd'hui qu'arrive dans les prochains
jours mais dans notre secteur on est
plus proche de 50 % il ya des films qui
ont aucun travailleur d'arrivée
présentement donc c'est très varié avant
très ferme
il ya aussi que quelques travailleurs il
y en a qui n'ont pas reçus du tout il y
en a qui sont rendus à 30% mais la
majorité en général sont en dessous de
50% présente
avez vous donc une crainte de moquer de
travailleurs pour les récoltes qui vont
commencer hors jeu voyait donc c'est
assez inquiétant comme on disait des
québécois qui sont prêts à venir nous
aider mais sa demande que la récolte de
fraises et framboises particulièrement
est très très intenses ils donc les
fraises doivent sortir des champs
rapidement et surtout avec la chaleur de
l'été donc il faut vraiment continuer
pierre cot en continu faut avoir une
équipe de travail stable qu'il a à tous
les matins pour faire les récoltes donc
c'est une année très inquiétante pour
les producteurs jusqu'à maintenant
là vous avez il ya des travailleurs
étrangers qui arrivent ya une période de
quarantaine il ya 14 jours où les
travailleurs étrangers doivent être
isolées est-ce que ça ça se passe bien
selon ce que vous en savez là ouais ça
va très bien me jetant comme question
avec les producteurs ils font leur
quarantaine il ça va super bien on fait
la prise à température donc sont très
patients ayant hâte de travailler donc
fait on
jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai vraiment connaissance d'aucun
incident ou cas d'infection donc ça va
super bien jusqu'à maintenant est-ce que
c'est difficile d'intégrer des nouveaux
travailleurs non expérimentés tous ces
québécois qui peuvent venir les gens qui
sont ici qui pourrait venir sur les
champs alors que les travailleurs
étrangers ont quand même développé une
expertise là où exactement dont ces
travailleurs là souvent c'est des gens
qui reviennent d'année en année dont qui
connaissent l'agriculture elle se
souvint sont mêmes travailleurs
agricoles dans leur pays dont qui
arrivent ici ans d'expérience sur nos
fermes de plusieurs années donc cédé
très bons travailleurs qui ont acquis
c'est l'efficacité dans leur travail
donc ça demande quand même une
adaptation ça demande un apprentissage
puis une endurance physique je vous
dirai donc mais après quelques semaines
les gens ils peuvent apprendre à faire
le bien le travail et il ya beaucoup de
gens qui apprécient ce type de travail
est-ce que de prolonger la subvention
salariale le programme fédéral
monsieur trop d'où l'annoncé aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est un avantage pour vous
un soulagement pour pour les producteurs
ouais c'est vraiment un soulagement donc
c'est une très bonne nouvelle qu'on a
eues aujourd'hui ce programme n'est
visiblement à donner un coup de main au
niveau des coûts liés à la masse
salariale donc dans nos productions lara
salariale est important puis à risque
d'être encore plus important cette année
avec le fait que justement on va devoir
engager plus de travailleurs qui ont
compensé en fait pour les travailleurs
angers qui seront pas au rendez-vous cps
que les fraises seront belle cette année
absolument ces garanties
non mais ça s'annonce très bien la
saison s'établit donc à stocker et à la
mi juin les fraises devons être prêts
décidément et ça va s'accompagner avec
le déconfinement la réouverture qui va
se poursuivre et qu'on espère qui va
fonctionner avec succès jennifer
crawford bon été merci beaucoup merci à
vous